now i understand one of the books
uh tell me if i've got this straight one
of the books
in your book club is actually being made
into a movie um one of the short stories
that we read
in my book club bellatrist called first
kill is being made into a tv show
for netflix and i could not be more
excited
i mean that's huge for anyone
who you know is maybe kind enough to be
participating in this conversation and
watching
you don't just easily get projects set
up at netflix
this is a very big deal and
congratulations on that thank you no
thank you
i mean i i'm just i'm so excited because
i think people are gonna
just love the show so much and for me i
love to read
my book club means so much to me and one
of my goals has always been like i want
to make
uh tv and movies that are as good as the
book and like that's always been
something that's inspired me and so to
get to have the opportunity to do that
um and the show is about vampires which
i'm obsessed with so it's it's gonna be
really fun
so thank you um i actually have a copy
here
of the book that you have currently for
your book club
we just announced that yesterday shirley
hazard um and it's a collection of short
stories which i thought would be
perfect for this month because you can
you know pick it up and put it down
um and the cover is also i have to say i
do judge books by their cover and that
one is gorgeous
it really is i love that you
uh read from the books uh
on your instagram and that we can watch
you
actually read why do you feel that
that's important because i find it so
incredibly engaging well i just think to
me
it's it's the only way to disconnect
really these days i feel like we live
our lives so much on our phones or
you know on our devices or on the
computer and we're always accessible and
to me like to be able to
take a book with me in into the bath or
like you know on a
you know into the park or just to be
outside and like have something where
there's no like alerts coming up there's
no notifications like i can really just
be engaged with one
thing and i feel like it calms my mind
um
i if i may i'll start the party the
ferguson's door
opened on a burst of light and voices
and on evie's sequel of surprise quite
as if
minna thought we had turned up uninvited
evie kissed her i'm like all right i'm
in i want to leave
and i also want you to read the whole
book to me like
i could just listen to you read the
whole thing would it be okay i want to
um
push to your site which you don't need
me you have 14.5 million followers on
instagram
which is all the more in reason that
bellatrist is so important because you
will
influence so many people uh to be
passionate about reading and we're just
going to go bananas on our website
uh for bellatrix because i think so
happy that you're following us oh yeah
absolutely i think it is just
incredible uh everybody emma roberts
holiday is available to stream on
netflix right now
emma thank you so much for taking the
time
with your beautiful baby um and
this extraordinary year thank you for
coming to our la studio
and taking the time uh out of your
most important time in you know in this
in your life right now to come and do
this with us i'm
no i was so excited i told the baby boy
i said we're going to see drew today
and he was so excited well tell the baby
boy i said
hello and he's going to have such a
great mom and i'm sure you'll be reading
to him which is going to be amazing
[Music]